[Music]
and you are one of the leading ladies of
the 90s
what do you remember about martin he
came to my house
and he was like didn't i tell you you're
going to be my leading lady you need a
footstool thank you
craziest fan mail you ever got there was
one fool
that would write me every single day
and said that he wanted me to send him
pictures of my feet
damn and even damn gina people say damn
gina
all the time it's the craziest thing but
i don't mind i love it i love that
people revere it so much
we never thought in a million years
people would consider us
iconic or that it would last or stand
the test of time
we are talking about the leading ladies
of the 90s
and you are one of the leading ladies of
the 90s 80s and 90s
thank you what do you remember about
martin when you
first got that show i had already gotten
another
uh pilot that had been picked up for
like seven episodes
he came to my house and he was like
didn't
i tell you whatever i get if it's a
movie or a tv show
you're gonna be my leading lady i really
want you to i can't believe you got me
begging you and i was like but martin i
thought you was just playing
so you didn't believe him no because
everybody says that and then
what was even more interesting to sheena
yes who i've known since i was 12 years
old had just come out
to california because she was during
pilot season so she was auditioning
and had just auditioned for pam oh
and so when he walks and he sees to she
says what are you doing here
not knowing that she was already picked
and so
she goes she's my best friend you know
she's i'm staying at her house until you
know probably season is over he goes
okay okay t-shirt please and so i was
like
even though something else was already
picked up in my soul i knew that this
was the thing that i needed to do
so why something
god i don't know i just felt like this
even though this was just a pilot
i felt like it was the right thing and
it turned out to be the
much bigger than any of us could ever
have imagined it
i never ever thought that we would be
iconic like yes it's engraved yes it is
but even more interesting i mean
i found out we're in the smithsonian
we're all shocked me martin tashina
like we were just going to work and
making people laugh
we never thought in a million years
people would consider us iconic
or that it would last or stand the test
of time
how often do people just yell vegeta
yes baby gina my son does it every
single
day of my life gina can you go make me
something to eat
so i don't mind when people call me that
because it means that
you know they really it means something
to them you know
how did you help craft that character of
gina well
um you know i think everybody had a hand
in it
i told you i had a meeting to get to but
you just had to try out the new bed
you know tommy and tashina and carl and
i we were all from the theater
and they surrounded all these people
from the theater around this one
comedian they had to establish the
character as being a strong
woman but then after a while you know
i got to play with martin i learned so
much i learned everything about comedy
from the men so you all had a a
ying and a yang that went back so you
used each other for so long
too like everybody did people love to
come by that set and just hang out
right who are some of the folks who come
by i think everybody in black hollywood
i even remember tony braxton just coming
to sit in the audience and
she started singing yeah snoop dogg
was actually on the show double g
because that be me and one day martin
and i were standing together
and he was just standing there going i
can't believe i'm in gina's apartment
and i was like
we both looked at the girls like oh
that's so cool
i think the hardest thing about doing
the martin show was not laughing right
well how did you not laugh because there
was something
he would do crazy stuff and then you
would do crazy stuff yeah
it was it was really hard because i knew
my job
was to make sure that we caught what
magic he was gonna put on the screen i
don't even know why you're still here
[Applause]
you do not know me i will bust your ass
and if i messed it up by laughing it
would be my bad
i'm really good at making sure that i
enhance the person next to me and
support them
and i could not laugh tommy was the
worst
tashina would always do stuff like
[Music]
you can hear it though right shut up
was there a favorite episode that you
have of martin
i would have to say i have two favorite
episodes okay one
is the plumber episode because i thought
everybody's work we all came together as
a group
and everybody shined in that episode i
especially love carl payne and martin's
work in that
we really like were a glue at that point
and then another ensemble episode was
the first halloween episode
which he was you know scared yes yeah
it was great come on we're gonna have a
stay on oh no we're not
you had crazy crazy fans when it came to
martin yeah we did
craziest fan mail you ever got there was
one fool
that would write me every single day
and said that he wanted me to send him
pictures of my feet
no fool i'm not doing that okay
he wanted
but then there was this one guy that
actually showed up he was sending me
stuff to the set and he actually showed
up
on the set and so people don't realize
that once you get
tisha there then she's a different she's
not gina
right she's not jeans
and so he saw the real t-shirt i was
like
i just thought you went off yeah cuz the
mouse so bad it scared him
and he ran yeah and you never saw him
again nope
nah i'm not scared no
so you don't need martin again i'm gonna
hurt you you got that girlfriend
[Music]
i wonder if it's hard for people to
understand now especially younger people
what that show meant at the time and to
see that kind of representation
on the screen how important it was for
folks
we didn't understand how important it
was because there were so many other
black shows going on at the time
right but what was important was that
there were two
young african-american people who were
in love
be my baby you my baby
we had you know cosby show
representation
but we really had two young people who
were having fun discovering each other
discovering life
i think that's what makes it so there
are so many songs about martin and gina
how many times have you been mentioned
in rap songs is that crazy how about
this
i keep millennials around me at all
times because you know a girl has to
transform and recreate and recreate
herself so
tisha keeps her millennials at all times
right
they were the ones who told me how much
the show meant to them and then
all the euphemisms that came out of
there even talk to the hand
okay so even this like you know talk to
the hand stuff
that came from i think the butt episode
where he i got him a bust of a butt he
said i was bushy for giving him a bust
of a butt and we started doing this in
each other's face it was just like
ad-lib that we were all doing to one
another and so the next time it aired
people started doing this i was like
somebody's gonna get their hand chopped
off you can't just do that
damn damn damn gina
baby and even damn gina damn genius i
say damn gina all the time
all the time it's the craziest thing you
get that one some too
i get that all the time but i don't mind
i love it i love that people revere it
so much
when do you realize this is a real hit
oh my god
it was the united negro college fund it
was an event for that and i think i saw
lawrence fishburne there and lawrence
looks at me he goes
tisha i'm so proud of your work i was
like really
it's a sitcom what are you talking about
and he goes
tisha it's really good i said it is
and he goes yeah that's like are you
sure because yeah
and so when someone like that says
yes when someone like that says yes then
it's a yes
is there going to be a reboot
everybody's been talking about this
you've been talking about
for a couple of years now that we're
going to have reboot it's so hard to say
because
one tommy's not here right and
the other thing is schedule it literally
boils down to schedule
every single one of us thank god it's
still working okay well let me ask you
this
what has everyone reconciled kissed and
made up because i know there were some
tough times there were some tough times
yes
we have we all sat down
and now it's like a year and a half ago
what most people don't know is like
three days after i separated out of the
blue
martin calls me and says i just want to
talk to you
can we meet for lunch let's bring to
sheena let's have lunch and let's all
talk
when you go into lunch and you're like
no
when he called me i screamed i s
i hadn't seen him since the last day of
the show
and we got to talk apologize love on one
another we were laughing at the end of
it
and we got to start appreciating
everything that we've all been through
that's what i think really life is all
about you
you go through these dark moments or you
go through down moments
and at the time you don't really realize
that this is
something that is needed to to uplift
you and make you bigger and better
at the end of it we are so good that's
great and we
are just supportive of one another
supportive of each other's families we
talk
it's all good can i ask you this is
everybody back in
is everybody i don't know that's a is
everybody what you're talking about
okay come on keep it coming because this
is fun in times like these how important
would it be to hear those voices
again when you're in these kind of
situations you just want to laugh
that's all and people are gravitating to
the show even more
because they just want levity
we made an impact and it was a big thing
for us and
i do not take it lightly and i'm so
grateful that i could
ease and heal people
with laughter i'll be right here
doing nothing as usual
i want to play this video for you okay
okay this is you ultra lord jesus it's
like one big family
we're like brothers and sisters we are
always always
cracking on each other we just have a
ball we do it we have a ball and it
comes off
what do you remember about that that
girl right there
i just remember wanting to keep it
together what do you mean like i
remember wanting to make sure that
everybody was good
everybody on set from the person who
took out trash
to the executive producers i remember
wanting to make sure that
everybody felt like we were a cohesive
team
and that it was my job to not only learn
my lines
but to kind of be like a first lady to
make sure that everybody was
still laughing and happy when the
cameras weren't whirling
but that wasn't pressure anybody else
put on me it was pressure that i put in
myself that's what i see
when i look at that okay here's another
one that i want to show you oh
why
[Music]
how cool is that i was 16
17 i was 17 years old doing racks to
riches
yes and singing the e.t theme oh wow
that's so crazy i look so young
by the way as someone who is
multi-talented just don't act you sing
you dance you do it all
go ahead give us finish that finish
[Music]
made the promos that's the promo
how are you doing because there's been a
lot of changes in your life so how are
you doing
i'm doing really well you know single
parenthood was an adjustment right
but i have to say it was the most
creative time i've
ever had in my entire life
everything that i ever wanted to create
i did
will you be ready to date again no why
not hell no
no come on i'm not ready to date nothing
i said creative that has nothing to do
with all that personal stuff i am so not
ready for that
no no because i think i'm still learning
who i am
and discovering who i am and i still
have a lot of growth and
and learning to do and i don't think
that i'm ready for that
at all i'm good i'm really good
no really no right now
i just want to concentrate on my growth
i want to concentrate on my spirit i
want to concentrate on
all my creates that's all i want to
concentrate on and my kids
and working and working and that's the
creative part i've been working my
behind off
come on now i already have my gift
i got my man all right holiday gifts
your favorite
holiday gift i was going through a
really tough time
and i had maybe seven dollars to my name
and i was scared and i was at zero
and i hadn't been at zero in a long time
and i had to choose
between getting my kid
some toys from rite aid for christmas
and a knife so that i can make christmas
dinner
i can't take my last and
spend this last on some toys that
little plastic army men that may not
mean anything to them i'm gonna make
christmas dinner
so i went and i bought the knife
for seven dollars at friday
and i made christmas dinner so i
wouldn't cut myself
and so the next morning
i'm scared to death i don't know
if my kids are going to
be disappointed they they went to the
tree they saw their video games i was
like you guys got to share them this
time
you know and they're like it's fine it's
great they were just so happy and kind
and
and they were like we got you so much
like you didn't have to give me anything
i just i was freaked out because i was
like where did they get money and and
and like we pulled our money together
and we got you something
and they got me a set of knives
oh wow and i burst it into tears
cause they don't understand what has
just happened
like i always say money's not my god and
the fact that
oh god i'm not supposed to do this here
the fact that my kids went and got me
some knives
when i was not in a good place i i
literally
ah t-shirt i cried like a baby
and they were looking at me like you
know what's wrong and i was like no
these are
happy tears starting over is not always
the easiest thing but is
the necessary thing it is a beautiful
devastation and
i realize that now and i'm just really
proud
this is right after your breakup right
after your yeah
after your marriage first when your
marriage broke up and you had
you got nothing nothing no one knows
that but i had nothing
nothing in the bank nothing i haven't
told anybody that i didn't have anything
and that everything was taken
i don't want to talk about that so how
did you get there you lost everything
you had nothing
i had some really incredible angels in
my life i had people who just
loved me where i was without all the
glitz and the glam and the everything
and they were okay with it and they were
okay with loving me
the way that i needed to be loved for
the first time in my life i really had
to re-examine me
and take care of me and feel the tears
the tears are okay
everybody's talking about mental
wellness and that is a
real thing and there's nothing to be
ashamed about especially in the
african-american community
we deal with a lot there's nothing wrong
with seeing a therapist
go to a therapist talk to people
get through it you will get through it
you
have no idea how strong you are until
you're in that fire
i had two reasons not to other than
myself was my two kids
and i wasn't going to and now look at me
like i've
rebuild i'm i'm doing everything that
i've ever wanted to do
and i'm the happiest i've ever been that
makes it so much better it makes it so
good
right now like all the success and life
in there it makes it so good
it makes it so not that i wasn't
appreciative before but i just never did
anything for myself you gotta understand
i've been working since i was seven
in acting i've been singing since i was
three but acting since i was seven
and everything was always for everybody
else i was
trying to keep my family afloat at five
years old i made a conscious decision
to help my family with bills i thought
that was important
right yeah but it was always for
somebody else
i wasn't worried about work because i
was responsible with my guests
that god gave me but it's really not
only about gifts it's about the effort
you put in
right i utilized my platform to uplift
to try to uplift my
my circumstances my family my community
i did everything that i was supposed to
do so
i'm just happy and i continuously look
back and appreciate the down moment
every single day i look back at where i
was on oh what was i doing this day
2018. oh my god
i i'm that i'm happy man